There are different forms of adversarial collaboration.
So one form is that you have people who disagree
on some theoretical issue trying to conduct
experiments that will resolve their differences
or reduce their differences.
And that is the first step in adversarial
collaboration, let’s see what we agree on
and then let’s try to trade our differences.
In some cases they’re friends, so you can
easily agree, although you agree that when
you write up the results you will write them
in two voices, so you don’t not commit yourself
to agreeing on the interpretation of the result.
Sometimes you need an arbiter to run the experiment.
That is when relations are more tense.
Instead of the reply and rejoinder format
you can agree to write a joint article in
which you first settle what you agree on and
then what you disagree on.
You have to be willing not to win, that is
you have to be willing to accept a draw and
to see that in the interest of science and
civility and other things a draw is better
than a win.
I happen to find a few people who are willing
to do that.
By the way, it is not easy because people
who think poorly of your work and of your
ideas get on your nerves and so you have to
overcome that.
The best of example of adversarial collaboration
that I have had was on issues of the boundaries
of intuition.
When is intuition marvelous and when is it
flawed and it was with Gary Klein, who is
a well-known author who was a great proponent
of expert intuition.
And so we worked for six or seven years together
trying to hammer out our differences about
whether intuition is valid or not and we came
out with an article that was actually--well,
it was a bit in two voices--but on most things
we agreed.
And that was the best adversarial collaboration
of all.